so mom let me just figure this out first
are you looking up how to do a braid yes
hi guys i'm matt welcome back to my
kitchen it's almost christmas time which
means it is the time of year for one of
my favorite treats swedish bread now if
you've never had swedish bread before
it's crunchy and sugary on the outside
it's sweet and pillowy on the inside
tastes a little bit like cardamom and
you can have it with jam on top you can
have it with ricotta on top whatever you
want i love it so much but unfortunately
this year i won't be traveling home for
the holidays so i'm joined by my mom
who's going to show me how to make it hi
everyone this is laura i'm really
excited to be sharing our family's
special swedish bread recipe with you
today this recipe was gifted to us many
years ago from our late friend mamie and
i really hope you enjoy it as much as
our family has i've never actually made
this before mom so you're gonna have to
help me out a little bit it can be
tricky but it's really worth it well i'm
ready to start cooking are you ready i
am ready let's do it
mom i have a pot in front of me what do
i need to do you're going to add your
milk your salt your butter
sugar and cardamom
i can really smell the cardamom in this
so cardamom is a very pungent spice so
start out with a little bit and if you
like it you can amp it up a bit we're
going to heat the milk and all the
ingredients until the sugar is dissolved
and the butter is melted i wasn't very
smart and i threw all my butter in as
one block i should have cut it up into
pieces i threw it in as a block too it
must be something familial oh my god
this smells so good did you grind your
own cardamom up i did grind my own can
you see that oh nice little can you see
the seeds
so this is white cardamom but it's green
it's not green it's white is this one of
those things where i can't see colors
again i think my sugar is pretty much
dissolved at this point my butter is
completely melted yes i think mine is as
well and i'm gonna just turn it off
we're going to set this aside to let it
cool and get ready for the next step
remember this is a really old recipe
this recipe is
probably over 50 years old proofing the
yeast a lot of times you don't need to
do that anymore but that's what the
recipe says to do proofing yeast was a
way to tell if your yeast was active we
just need to wake these guys up you're
just making sure that the yeast you have
is potent we're gonna add some warm
water if it's too cold the yeast won't
activate so we're gonna add that to our
bowl one package of active dry yeast got
it and a teaspoon of sugar you just want
to mix this up and it should begin to
foam up because it's it's got sugar and
yeast love sugar let this rest for a few
minutes and it should foam up cool cool
we'll be right back oh wow it's already
foaming up all right mom my yeast looks
really really happy it's foamed up it
almost looks like a pint of beer mine
looks like fireworks going off in it
it's like
we need to pour the warm milk mixture
into a bowl mine's already in a bowl
gonna add the yeast it's like latte art
we're going to add one egg lightly
beaten you're going to whisk it all
together until everything's blended and
mimi only made this for christmas she
only made this for christmas every
christmas she would come over to our
house and gift us a beautiful loaf of
this bread wrapped with ribbon and a
nice jar of raspberry preserves to go
with it okay so next step is we're going
to get a larger bowl and we're going to
add and transfer our everything mixture
to the big bowl ah this smells so good
it does wait until it's done literally
smells like our house at christmas yeah
next we're going to sift the flour and
gradually add it to the mixture the
reason why we're doing a cup at a time
is because as you're mixing the flour
into the liquid you're shooting for a
texture that is springy when it's
pressed and not too sticky we're gonna
have to get us to a point where we can
knead it oh she's getting thick oh no i
just made one of those jokes i'm gonna
start using my hands it's still oh
actually it might be close i'm putting
another half a cup in you'll feel the
texture change when you get close i feel
like i'm right on the cusp it's still a
little sticky so i'm gonna just add a
little bit more flour
i'll tell you what
this is more work than i thought it
would be i'm gonna transfer mine to the
cutting board and knead how long are we
gonna need this for gonna knead it about
15 minutes okay we'll we'll be right
back i am working up a sweat right now
you need to exercise more what what's
the texture we're looking for again if
you notice it's not sticking to your
hands it's surface is clean and it's
tacky but not sticky and when you poke
it with your fingers it should spring
back you should have a ball of dough
like this
can you see
good
you've got a large large bowl
a little bit of room temperature butter
probably about maybe a tablespoon and
we're just gonna
smear it around the bowl to coat my bowl
looks pretty well greased how's that
looks good then what you do is you're
gonna take your bowl of dough you're
going to put it in
and just make sure you get some butter
around all of it i just take it and
roll it around the bowl so next we're
going to let it rest cover it up until
it's about double in size all right i
will see you in a little bit then sounds
good
so it's been about an hour and as you
can see my dough has doubled in size
we're going to gently take it out of the
bowl and we're going to divide it in two
i'm going to divide one half into three
pieces all right we're going to make
three rubs that are about 14 inches in
height so it's a combination of
stretching and rolling it's so pillowy
this is more fun than i was
thinking all three of my pieces of dough
rolled out they're all relatively even
and uniform
the one on the left connected to the
middle they are pinched together and you
take the one on the right and also pinch
it together now they are all pinched
together so i've got all three of my
pieces pinched together how do i do a
braid you take the right strand bring it
over the middle and pull the middle
strand to the right then you bring the
left strand over and pull the middle
strand to the left oh this is easy you
pinch them together and then you kind of
tuck them under does it look like a
braid yeah you want to see oh yes yep
yours looks good yay so now you take
that
and
you're going to put it on a lined
baking sheet i don't know if you can see
it oh wow yours is way longer than mine
so now we're going to cover this again
with a damp towel and set it aside while
we do our second one and then we're
going to let them rest again just like
we did before
so we're almost ready to bake our bread
and what we need to do is do a quick
light water wash you don't want to give
it a bath you just want to give it a
light coating gently no pressure because
you don't want to deflate the bread
you can see all the little specks of
cardamom in it you just want to do a
light coating so the sugar sticks to it
so next we're going to give it a light
sprinkling of coarse sugar and it should
stick to the bread what kind of sugar
are you using i'm using decorative
sugar
how liberal can i be with the sugar as
liberal as you want nice i think my loaf
looks good that looks good matt
can you see mine oh yours is big so
we're going to repeat what we did with
this loaf with the last loaf and bake
them at 350 degrees you'll know that
they're done when they turn a nice
golden brown and when you tap them on
the bottom they sound hollow
it is actually the next day we let our
bread cool overnight mine looks really
good mine looks really good too that
looks really nice matt thank you thank
you i learned from the best ah what say
we cut these in half and take a look at
the inside sounds good
oh wow
yours look really good it's got more
height than mine it's so spongy it's the
sign of a good breath this looks great
it looks nice and brown on the outside
it's nice and fluffy on the inside let's
toast these up how do you like your
bread i like my swedish bread toasted
lightly with a little bit of butter and
jam i love mine with jam i also like it
with a little bit of ricotta and some
honey on top you see that well that
looks really nice what say we give it a
shot sounds like a plan all right
really good like you remember i don't
think it's quite as good as yours the
cardamom is really subtle it's really
festive and it's fluffy on the inside
the cardamom is not too strong it's
sweet but it's not too sweet it's very
spongy thank you so much for showing me
how to make this this is one of my
favorite things to have every year it's
important to have things that remind you
of family and friends and good times and
when you make them it reminds you of
people
who you care about i think we're
fortunate that we can do this virtually
and feel like at least we shared a
ritual that's important to our family
together and and i really like the fact
that it's been passed down to another
generation and now we shared it with all
of you i hope you guys enjoy the recipe
as much as i have and as much as my
family does let us know what you think
in the comments below or message me on
instagram i wish everyone a happy and
safe holiday thanks again bye bye guys
happy holidays oh yes
[Music]
you